our responsibility is to always inspire
vanessa bryant's 38th birthday was
inspired for sure chock full
of sweet family memories the late kobe
bryant's widow celebrated her special
day on tuesday
with the help of friends and family she
shared
this sweet family pic with her daughters
17 year old natalia
three-year-old bianca and nine-month-old
capri
alongside the caption thanks to my girls
for ordering these flowers and pinatas
for mama
how cute is that the perfect way to
celebrate her birthday
and cinco de mayo in her stories vanessa
shared
this close-up shot of that fountain full
of flowers
and you might want to grab the tissues
because natalia's card to her mama
read you are the strongest person i know
and i am
so grateful to have you as my mom i will
always be the ethel to your lucy
the birthday girl also shared this shot
of a bunch of balloons from her girls
and natalya bianca and capri kept their
dad's birthday tradition alive
bringing their mama her favorite
starbucks drinks in the morning
she's amazing kobe and vanessa were
married for 18 years
and would have celebrated their 19th
wedding anniversary on
april 18. we met actually a video
shoot that i was filming she was there
and we actually had when we first met we
have it on tape
so we get to show our kids earlier in
the day vanessa revealed on instagram
that she recently found a letter from
kobe that she had never opened
you got a three piece on styling
trying to i gotta keep up with my wife
the envelope was addressed to the love
of my life
from to poppy and vanessa said she
intentionally waited until her b day to
read the letter
explaining quote it gave me something to
look forward to
she also added that she was missing the
love of my life and my sweet little
mamacita
kobe and their 13 year old daughter
gianna died in a helicopter crash
in january and on tuesday they were
both top of mind vanessa shared this pic
of their youngest daughter writing capri
looks just like her daddy
in gigi's outfit friends of kobe and
vanessa made sure to send the mom of
three some birthday love
sierra and russell wilson sent flowers
so did kris jenner and kim and khloe
kardashian
vanessa's friend lala anthony sent over
some sweets
and when eti caught up with lala in
april she gave us an update on how her
pal is doing
i talked to her every single day and
just you know continue to
pray for her and stay positive for her
she
i tell her every day she's the strongest
woman i know and
i'm really really proud of just how
she's handling everything and just
want to continue to be there you know as
much as i can for her as a friend she's
just
an amazing and amazing human being just
just amazing
you